-How are you?
-I'm good. How are you?
-Good. It's very lovely
to have you here.
This is not your first book.
-No.
-But what was the genesis,
and what set you off the pat
to write this book
about, really, the moment
we're living in right now?
-So, I really wanted to writ
something that was part memoir
but was also, I think,
encapsulating
a lot of what women have bee
going through right now,
especially
in the last few years,
since 2017's Me Too movement
and Time's Up and all of tha
and this sort of condensed sense
of palpable rage and chang
that feels uncontrollable
and really terrifying,
and to talk a lot about
leaning into that
and not being afraid of it
and to know that the chang
that we're sort of seeking
as a culture and as a countr
and as individual genders
is going to come when
we are in our own discomfort
And we're not afraid
of it anymore.
-One of the things that
a paperback gives you
an opportunity to do
is add something, revise things.
-Yes.
-In this case, you had an
afterword where it seems -
I guess you wrote
six months ago --
about the candidates
in the Democratic field
and how important it was to have
sort of a diverse group
of candidates.
And basically,
just this idea of representation
and how that
can help avoid moments
like the one
we're living in now,
if you have
more voices in power.
-Yes. Well, statistically,
it's actually proven, too,
that, if you have more women
in positions of power,
if you have more equality
sexual harassment
and sexual assault
actually goes down
in the workplace.
That is a fact and a statistic
And I think one
of the most important things
we're seeing about --
not only this election,
but the powerful women
like Ayanna Pressley
and Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
you know, coming into powe
and coming into office,
is that we're actually seein
the living embodiment
of who we are
in those positions of power,
which allows us to feel like
we can capably become
those types women someday
in our own lives.
So I think it's so important
that what we're seeing right now
is a lot of different type
of women who are running.
It keeps narrowing down.
I myself
am a huge Elizabeth Warren fan
I've endorsed her.
I think
she's absolutely incredible.
And what's so great about it
though, is that there's options,
and we didn't really
have that before.
So now that we have the options,
we can actually talk about
the fundamental ideas and plan
behind who those candidates ar
and why we want them.
-Another thing you did was
you wrote an epilogue,
which is a letter
to your daughter.
-Yes.
-And I certainly felt this
as well, in this moment --
you describe in this era
we're living through,
where there's
a lot to be angry about
and a lot of, I think,
reflecting on the way
we treated different genders
and having two boys --
I think about it all the time.
-Yeah.
-Has being a parent informed
the way you think about this
and the way write about this
-Oh, it's changed everything
and so many
of my girlfriends, too --
Like, I imagine, for you,
it must be a complex feeling
to have two sons
in this particular era
with this particular president
just as anyone who has,
you know, girls,
who's raising girls.
But, for me, I think
one of the hardest things
that I had to come to grips with
as a parent
was that
I really couldn't control it
and I couldn't control
the outcome.
And I couldn't control
protecting them.
I couldn't control making them
better in certain instances.
There's just so much
you can't control --
and letting go of that,
but knowing you can be
the most empathic nurturer
and supporter
through the good and the bad
with your child
was something that was
a real harnessing moment for m
in getting to write that lette
to her at the end of the book.
-You talk about lacking contro
as a parent.
My wife had gave birth
in the lobby of our --
-I know.
-Which was a --
you know, that was a perfect
example of a lack of control
[ Light laughter ]
Because...
if you could control it,
you wouldn't do that.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-You had a similar labor issue
that was, again,
a lack of control.
-I also refer to it
as a labor issue.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
That's what women call it
in the hospital.
"Sir, I'm having a labor issue!"
[ Laughter ]
"Sir!"
I -- It was
actually like a day --
the day after Trump had won,
and I was coming up the stairs
in the subway
at Columbus Circle
and started
to feel contractions,
and I realized that I was
actually, like, going --
about to give birth
in the subway.
-Yeah.
-As I was coming up the stairs
and it was really scary,
and there was --
all of these different thing
that -- happening,
and I'm including
a wonderful homeless man
who offered me an orange
to help.
[ Light laughter ]
-Sure.
-That was great,
and then, also, you know,
offered to help give birth
It was
a very intense experience.
And I was, in my mind,
freaking out,
and I chronicled this
in the book.
And I was just like,
"I don't know if I'm --
you know, the depression
from Hillary Clinton losing,
you know,
is making my water break,
or if I'm having, like,
a miscarriage
because Trump has -- has won."
I know that's really intense
but that's how it felt
in that moment.
-[ Chuckling ] Sure.
-Yeah.
And it actually just turned ou
I was having an anxiety attack
[ Laughter ]
That's all it was --
it was just like
a huge anxiety attack.
-There were a lot, yeah.
Hospitals are filled of people
with doctors being like,
"Ma'am, you're not having
your baby right now."
-That's exactly what it was.
-"It's just a strange man
is president,
and this is
a totally normal thing."
-Yes. That's right.
-We were -- I was not in -
over my career,
I was not in many films,
but we were in a film together
-We were in
a very important film together
a very important film.
-I remember. I remember.
-We were in a film called
"Spring Breakdown."
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-It's legendary.
-It's a legendary film --
I think growing every year
-It is.
-Which helps because
it started very small.
-I don't know
why it wasn't nominated
for the Oscar this year.
-Yeah.
Overlooked again.
-I mean -- Overlooked again!
-Yeah.
-You guys.
-But a wonderfully fun film...
-It was.
...with Amy Poehler
and Rachel Dratch
and yourself and --
-Yeah. Parker Posey.
-Parker Posey.
-Like, just fun.
-A good group of people.
-Yeah.
I don't know where you can
check it out, but it's...
-Yeah.
-It might be, like,
in a used DVD
in the Columbus Circle Subway.
-Yeah, there's --
I know there's one --
there's one Blockbuster
left in Alaska
that I think has it.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thank you so much for
making the time and being here
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a pleasure to be here.
-I like talking to you.
Really appreciate it.
Amber Tamblyn, everybody.